la cds ou d'anglais la merkel au coeur
d'un scandale sanitaire de députés
conservateurs sont accusés d'avoir
touché des commissions sur des contrats
d'achat de masques et ce dès le début de
la pandémie en endossant le rôle
d'intermédiaire entre les fabricants et
les ministères chargés de les commander
ces derniers auraient récolté
d'importantes sommes d'argent une
affaire rendue publique qui a poussé les
deux députés à quitter leurs fonctions
les préjugés du public sur ma personne
ont atteint un niveau qui est
insupportable pour moi mais surtout pour
mon parti en tant que membres du
bundestag
j'aurais dû agir avec plus de
sensibilité dans mes activités
entrepreneuriales surtout dans la
situation particulière de la pandémie
afin d'éviter d'autres dommages à mon
parti je me retire de mon mandat au
bundestag
des démissions qui éclabousse le parti
conservateur de la chancelière allemande
alors que des élections doivent avoir
lieu le 14 mars prochain dans les länder
du bade wurtemberg et de rhénanie
palatinat
ces scrutins test pourrait donner le ton
des élections législatives prévues fin
septembre selon une partie de la classe
politique allemande angela merkel
devrait prendre la parole avant cette
échéance afin de rassurer la population
le scandale impliquant les députés de la
cd ou est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
de ceux qui répandent le mythe de la
conspiration
selon lequel toute la classe politique
agi par intérêt personnel lorsqu'il
s'agit de la politique de lutte contre
la pandémie
la chancelière doit maintenant faire un
discours à la nation pour éviter une
perte de confiance imminente une fin de
mandat difficile pour angela merkel
alors que son gouvernement est
lourdement critiqué quant à sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire le parti de céder
ou est en difficulté dans les sondages
une enquête publiée par le quotidien
allemand bild a révélé que seuls 32% des
électeurs prévoient de voter pour le
parti conservateur soit le niveau le
plus bas atteint par le parti depuis un
an